we have two journalists in conversation
with each other next Peter wolodarsky
who is the editor of DM in conversation
with Maggie Haberman who is the White
House correspondent for the New York
Times and I guess we're ready so please
welcome them both thank you
[Applause]
hello everyone and hello Maggie
Peter it's a hard act to follow I guess
there is a meta meaning to this act like
we're extremely privileged and and
honored that you're here today because
you everyone who's following American
politics has to follow you because you
you are the one reporter that is really
the trump reporter who you are following
him all the time writing about him
getting interviews you have an extremely
hectic schedule you sleep anything I
don't and I have not slept much since I
got here but he Trump Trump has a habit
of dominating everybody's life in u.s.
politics and certainly for White House
reporters so it has been a very very
busy year but you came here but I came
here it was a wonderful break so thank
you is this your first trip to Europe
since he became president it is it's my
second trip to Europe since he became
president I flew with him on Air Force
One to France in July because he wanted
to attend the Bastille Day Parade which
was a literally a two-day trip and then
he went back how do you manage this I
mean you have you have three kids small
kids you live in New York and you cover
the president who's in Washington how do
you deal with this I mean it's it's been
a it's been a tough year and it's been a
head anticipated that things would end
when the campaign ended because I didn't
think that he was likely to be the
president even though I did I did think
he had a chance of winning and so
obviously things have changed you manage
you do the best you can it's been the
hardest on the kids and I think that the
election in the US was very intense for
children I think in a way that for
school children in a way that people
didn't really understand at the time but
Trump as I said before he just sort of
fills the room and
and then sucks up all the oxygen I mean
that filters down to everything so it's
difficult but you know the thing about
being in New York is that he's a
president who tries to act as if he's
not actually in the White House I was
just watching his rally on a livestream
from last night in Pensacola Florida and
it was as if he was a candidate again I
mean he kept talking about the rigged
system and then he's there and he's in
charge he leads this system so it's I
think what he's gonna try to do is make
himself the the the fixer of the system
based on some of what he was talking
about at the rally but it's it works
well to not be in Washington for this
presidency and he wakes up very early in
the morning right around probably around
now in the US now it's 5:00 6:00 a.m.
6:00 a.m. okay and how does a typical
morning looks for the president but you
have a store right now out at the New
York Times not out yet it's coming out
in the next couple of hours about it's
his habits right it's about who he is it
was originally supposed to be timed
around the one-year anniversary of the
election but it has taken on a different
form in terms of the timing but it's
yeah it's about what his day is like
what you know his Twitter habits his TV
habits he's extremely sensitive to
people characterizing how much time he
spends watching TV which if you read his
Twitter feed is pretty obvious because
he tweets at Fox News and he quotes
things he's just heard and you can often
look at what time segments just aired
and then see he'll tweet about it a few
minutes later but when you take note of
that he gets very upset so he's probably
watching television he's gonna attack
you on Twitter there's a story when the
story goes up I don't think it'll be up
in two hours but there's a good 50%
chance he will make his feelings known
on Twitter about this all right how does
that feel for you when you're personally
attacked by the President of the United
States so he has not done that to me
personally since he became president but
he did during the campaign quite a bit
it's it's unusual because the way it's
it's almost like cyberbullying the way
he uses his Twitter feed he he goes
after you and
and his swarm of followers come at you
and then long after he's moved on to
some new grievance they still carry his
grudges so it's some on the other hand
it's it's simply a more intense version
of the types of letters we used to get
in the mail in a newsroom but but it
comes with a certain level of vitriol
that I've never seen before has it
changed you I don't know if it's changed
me I mean I think it's what I worry
about is that I'm getting a little numb
to certain things and it's taken a very
long time for me to get numb but a lot
of what we're seeing with with Trump is
so incredibly it's it's more than
unusual I mean that some of the language
that he uses it's beyond divisive
rhetoric some of its very dangerous and
especially on certain topics and so I
think there's a difference between being
surprised by what he does and people
being outraged by what he does I don't
think people should be surprised by what
he does anymore at this point he's shown
that there's not much of a bottom to
what he's gonna do in terms of it
changing me I just think that I've
gotten inured to it to a degree that
that has surprised me that that's the
one area I'm surprised enough I've
actually gotten numb to some of the but
I don't think it's changed me I mean I I
think I mean I I'm I'm pretty cynical
about politicians he's fearful and
you're one of the few reporters that
have actually been covering Trump not
only for this last year and on the
campaign but for the last I mean several
years so 10 years right well you were in
New York covering him as a reporter for
the tabloids as a tabloid reporter you
cover Donald Trump in some way or
another but I didn't really get to cover
him intensively until 2011 when he was
considering running for president and it
looked a lot like it did in 2015 but
that time he didn't run and because he
didn't run one of his aides came to me
in May of 2015 and said Trump is gonna
announce his candidacy on June 16th of
2015 it was a few months later and we
want you to write about it and I said no
and he said why and I said because I'm
not writing a word until he actually
runs I don't believe he will run and I
had good reason not to believe he would
run he had been flirting with running
for president since 1987
and we all believed he wouldn't actually
do it because he would have to release
his tax returns he would have to you
know make more clear about his actual
net worth which has been the subject of
some speculation that he might be
overstating it
he still hasn't released his tax returns
so it turns out I was wrong about that
but you've seen him a lot more than
other journalists closely I mean you've
interviewed him many many times met him
how is he on that on a personal level I
mean it depends it depends it's he he
does have this ability to be funny and
charming that you don't see when he's
standing at a rally you know talking
about the rigged system but but usually
the conversation he's always feel like
he's selling you know I mean he's a
Salesman and he is always selling so
he's trying to sell me on some picture
of what he wants reality to be he never
treats he never treats life as if it is
filled with objective truths its truths
as he wants it to be and one of the
challenging things for me certainly but
I think for all reporters is that to
cover Donald Trump accurately in his
mind is covering him unfairly and that's
it arouses these reactions in him that
don't seem rational but he seems to
respect you know I don't think he
respects me I think he I think he deals
with me I think that everything with him
is he's the most transactional person I
have ever met in my life
what do you mean by that I mean
everything is a deal everything is about
what what his objective is and so his
objective is he's fascinated the times
Holt looms very large in his personal
psychology short times New York Times
why is that because when he was growing
up in New York and he wanted to be taken
seriously I mean there's this whole life
long thread of wanting to be taken
seriously and so he was a real estate
developer in Queens and he did not have
glitzy projects on Fifth Avenue at that
point he wanted to be taken seriously
and the time New York Times represents a
cross-section of New York elites that he
wanted to be part of and when he you
know getting the New York Times's versus
actual treatment in his mind is is a big
big focal point the New York Times is
the first interview that he did after he
was elected and he came to our offices
we didn't go to him so that I think
tells you a lot
and where's that's why he deals with me
I mean if I were not at the Times I do
not yes he's known me a long time but if
he if I were not at the Times I don't
think I would hear I've heard something
somewhere that you you enjoy interacted
with him interacting with him I don't
know that I said I enjoy interacting
with him I think what I said is that I
like that's okay I can find him charming
and engaging which as I was saying you
don't normally see when he's in these
public forums but but I do find him
interesting and I I mean he's a he's a
reporter he is a fascinating character
and one can be both fascinated and still
vigilant and aware of how divisive and
in some cases dangerous what he says and
this has moved from just being a story
for Americans this is a global story now
and and there is there's a war words
between the president and the North
Korean regime the leader of North Korea
where will that end I hope somewhere not
terribly look I think that I think that
the president's rhetoric has alarmed a
number of people within his
administration who have spent some time
trying to get him to do less of that
there are some there are some members of
his circle who actually have a more
muscular view of how the US should be
dealing with North Korea that might
surprise people but generally speaking
you know the hope is that this ends with
with words and nothing more but he is
certainly engaging in activities we're
not used to but given all that you know
about him how would you think he would
react when a foreign leader insults him
attacks him verbally well he takes it
personally and he doesn't let her he
takes everything personally everything
he completely conflates himself with the
institutions he represents it is it is
very you know the state is me and
and and so if he's insulted he will tend
to be impulsive and reactive he is
constantly reactive that is the hallmark
of this presidency that doesn't pretend
anything great in the context of your
question but I also don't want to
predict where it might go should we
brace for impact
um I think you should just take
everything one day at a time as we all
are Maggie Haberman thank you very much
indeed for for doing this interview
thank you and we'll have the
conversation later on thank you thank
you
[Applause]